[Musik]
ich hatte einfach ist lifestyle kriege
aber ich bin für die sache aber halt
machen das knack knack gut bin für meine
kollegen natur
[Musik]
auch wer jetzt den stil vor seinem
aufenthalt dass einfach alles mal aber
und xl bin ich bin ja quasi ich weiß
aber nicht einfach immer wieder noch mit
denen werde ich mich nicht wohl fühle
mich mehr
[Musik]
bis vor kurzem wäre es für emils eltern
undenkbar gewesen ihnen allein zu lassen
zu groß war die angst er könne sich
etwas antun
ich vertraue versorgt das nicht ganz im
chaos sind herzlich macht jede wichtig
und jetzt noch so ich da noch so nie war
es so dass mal spannend wieviel sterben
lassen - und gibt uns die vielen
galaxien werden miteinander sind user
außerhalb seines elternhauses fühlte
sich emil lange unverstanden und einsam
sein seelisches leid behielt er für sich
bis zum zusammenbruch
die geschichte des 14 halbjährigen emil
ist kein einzelfall immer mehr
jugendliche geraten unter druck
neben psychiatrische und psychologische
hilfe an
[Musik]
die bunte richtlinie ziemlich frage
stellt und das sehr einfach geschafft
hat er wacht den wahnsinn getrieben war
schon einfacher für mich sie das ganze
leider nicht normal so normal geworden
ich bin immer noch leader spezialisiert
und so habe ich sehr oft einfach und so
lange nicht viel sagt wenn ich bin ich
finde gut genug für zwei ich bin zum
tanz erster vermarkter nicht gott gott
und da passen viele sehr viel von mir
abgewandt und sagt so die komische die
komische e mail
denn jetzt muss ich mit dem los es läuft
mit dem fall so klein sind sehr viel
mehr abgewandert und betrank sich hat ja
nicht nur schlimmer gemacht so dass ich
einfach so ich meine kamera gefühlt und
danach mit verleiten das ist schlimm für
mich gesetzt
[Musik]
so mobben kreisky wurzeln umwelt schöpft
wurde wenn man müsse als spitalplatz von
einem kopftuch rapper ali inzwischen
dass ich dass ich das was ludwig wie
vereint hat dass der e mail fertig
machen
das war vielleicht hätte ja ja es ist
wirklich so ich angst gar nicht schwarz
hamburger schlachtvieh ist gebrochen so
stress und angst vor der mannschaft
ich bin immer weniger schultern also
schaut sie war verletzt und wollte
sofort bin verdanke dir das läuft hier
falsch und andererseits gibt es jetzt
einfach indem man gespürt wird das so
dass noch da ist
in das fahrwasser ich bin verletzt
das klappt aber ich weiß dass es klappt
das ja
[Musik]
meine familie hat mir ganz und meine
kollegen so gewirkt als hätte ich es
lieber vor dem griff egal wer die
umstand bin ich auch jemand geschrieben
und dann plötzlich gefühl vor unglück wo
es mir sind und ich denke dass
videospiele und deine machen und einfach
so panik habe dann aber vor eine ursache
und alles was außer und ich bin einfach
froh und habe mich so unwohl gefühlt und
auch sonst nie erlebt kapital fast jede
marke big four im zuge einer rache und
ja das machen auch vor den zug springen
davon abhalten es nicht klappt was dann
passiert dann bemerkt dass mit mutter
gefeiert hat kam es nicht zum vorteil
teilweise messerscharfe analyse hat
problem kann dann das plötzlich und und
ich habe ehrlich nicht senkt wird
innerlich nicht gefehlt und auch
umgekehrt gilt vor allem dass ich
glaub's aus afrika und das ist dann ist
das loch
benny konnte seine krise nicht länger
verbergen
in seiner verzweiflung geriet er in eine
essstörung mehrere zusammenbrüche
folgten seine lehrerin unterstützte ihn
beim gang zur schulpsychologin und zur
ambulanten therapie
[Musik]
bennys vater war für einen attraktiven
job mit den vier kindern nach zürich
gezogen nachdem sich die eltern getrennt
hatten erhielt der vater das alleinige
sorgerecht für die kinder
beim umzug von australien in die schweiz
war benny acht jahre alt darunter und
das ist teilweise noch violinen und ganz
lustig an mehr oder weniger ohne mutter
denn aufgewachsen
wie ist das für dich rufen rückblickend
ist okay aber damals ist nicht ok damals
zog sich eine ganze stunde bis jetzt
plötzlich lag sie aber jetzt
ich würde mich also ich hab mich
hausmann spektrum ich dann gemacht wenn
ich fit bin
die nun die fans also unabhängig und so
zielbewusst damit abhängig von den
menschen halt immer alles alte land
[Musik]
auch das klavierspiel brachte er sich
benny selber bei dieses lied komponierte
er als matura arbeit ein wendepunkt in
seinem leben
[Musik]
es ist ein fatales 26 das ist einfach so
otto hat einmal das kleid dass es stolz
ist das wirklich ist roland hahn nach
den vielen jahren ich sah dass ich nicht
singen kann hat er jetzt endlich zeit
dass drei bringen mit dem also zwei
wochen nach stolpe und rumpelt es wird
auch für mich so viel mehr als nur das
lied when i was 17 als sein vater starb
seither lebt er allein in dieser 5
zimmerwohnung die älteren geschwister
waren schon vor längerer zeit ausgezogen
die bereits gewonnene unabhängigkeit
wurde zur pflicht
es ist so dunkel und leer und dann fühle
ich mich und das argument
doch dann geschrieben meine schwester
schrieb und deine kleider alles dass ein
so schwieriger geworden ist einmal
gestellt
foto schule beim anruf staat ich super
auf das am besten ohne den vater nach
schweiz mit dem bett gekommen ist sollte
es wenig dass die ganze familie wir in
das ist der sound der ältesten töchter
an allen brettern und ich baby
[Musik]
jugend psychiatrischer notfalldienst des
kantons zürich wie damals benny und e
mails suchen hier jährlich über 600
kinder und jugendliche soforthilfe
[Musik]
zu ihrer körpers zur gedanke dass zudem
lieber wenn ich das richtig verstanden
ich dann schon mal selber weder dass du
mit kopf geschlagen
[Musik]
ein einziger fehler nur ein einziger das
geschlecht ich stück ganz nach dem
ganzen planeten spielen ganze universum
und da gedanken umlagert wurde das ist
für sie jetzt ganz neu nein das ist also
immer angst gemacht hatte und so tun
jetzt halt nicht mitmachen
wie würde es dennoch wieder stärker das
so die usa vor ich im notfall ich nicht
zu viel zu machen also nicht zu
übertragen und auf der andere sieht eine
der bis verpassen oder und wenn jetzt
das kind sei dabei und ich wollte mir
bleiben dort ständig in einem
spannungsfeld sie ja sofort in klinik ii
wieder aber einer klinik ist dramatisch
salat machen nicht immer auf 100
prozentige sicherheit oder in der stunde
oder ein nackt und wo man im kindersitz
finden wenn ich den siegpunkt thomas
müller guth im ambulanten also drei oder
mehr muss man als kind vor sich selber
schützen oder in ganz alten verhalten
muss das kind vor der familie oder vor
schulen oder was auch immer den mobbing
in der schule unterstützt also da immer
da die mutter abhängig oder liebe dein
kind heim auch eine sage mir einen
karstadt jetzt das kind vor dem suizid
gedanken und handlich gut wie nie das
hat keine konkrete plan chaos ist und
für eine firma mit einem nie
konfrontiert dass er wahnsinnig schwer
entscheiden
der experte die sicherheit kg was kassel
sehr wertvoll sie was man nicht kenne
ich ihn mir eine dreiviertelstunde wie
die komplexe diagnostische abklärung
machen und mit dem e für löschen wir
sind für wehrmänner kawasaki wo es für
lösche und wirte risiko beurteilen ich
mache kam in ein hohes niveau
während therapeuten er wieder
architekten die römer den und das haus
mit der familie zusammen
in den letzten zehn jahren haben sich
die notfall zahlen mehr als verzehnfacht
sie steigen nicht nur absolut sondern
auch in relation zur bevölkerung ja für
jahr
mich beunruhigt das sehr dass die
notfall zahlen in unserem notfalldienst
sehr stark angestiegen sind und das land
durch eigentlich einerseits auch positiv
dass immer mehr jugendliche in der krise
unsere hilfe auch suchen
andererseits ist es aber auch ein
ausdruck einer allgemeinen jugend krise
dass der leistungsdruck und der druck
durch vergleiche in sozialen medien
immer mehr gestiegen ist und sich immer
mehr jugendliche auch wirklich selbst
gefährden durch suizidalität durch sich
selber ritzen und so weiter wie ich es
denn mit dem 3
die selber zu verletzen es weniger es
sind halt immer liegt dixie und ich
mache es nicht ein liter sind ja okay
wenn du noch so drakonisch der seilbahn
oder mit der spritze oder so hat zu der
vierten von sieben tagen der woche bei
uns melden
das ist mir ganz ganz wichtig
erforderten dass ein rasch
also die ersten anzeichen sind oft der
rückzug aus dem familienleben dass man
sie nicht mehr erreicht mit ihnen nicht
mehr ins gespräch kommt als eltern dass
sie sich zurückziehen ihren hobbys die
lust verlieren an allen aktivitäten dass
sie sich von ihrem gleichaltrigen
freundin zurückziehen und da nichts mehr
unternehmen und alarmstufe rot ist
natürlich wenn suizidale lebensmüde
gedanken geäußert werden wenn man sieht
dass sie sich selbst verletzen oder wenn
sie gar nicht mehr in die schule gehen
können
benny ist früher unterwegs als an jedem
anderen morgen denn heute ist sein 18
geburtstag und seine klasse hat ihm eine
überraschung versprochen war sichtlich
enttäuscht aber die kollegen ist erwacht
sind heißt das nicht viel
[Musik]
mai
in der klasse fühlt es sich benny immer
gut aufgehoben
dieser rückhalt gab ihm auch in der
größten krise sicherheit weißen
mitteilte
hier wird macht sich lustig mich also
ich weiß einfach dass ich mich wohlfühle
kann und dass das schlimmste nicht
eigentlich dankbar london und einfach
mit platz gefunden heißt es wieso ist
das ganze rad und aber ich bin nach
einer verdienen teile am auto zusammen
emil wohnt bei seinen eltern
sein älteres geschwister ist bereits
ausgezogen
emils probleme machten auch vor dem
elternhaus nicht halt mit schul wechseln
versuchten die eltern damals ruhe in
sein leben zu bringen ohne erfolg wort
von der show nach kriegsende fuß kommt
alles hätte mit dort abgeladen applaus
im verständnis für erwachsene sondern
hatte die heime und der ccc sehr
belastet hieß es denn auch nicht
wirklich geld kommen salzburgs mit
kooperativen so ist das halt ich sie das
weiße besonnenheit
ich glaube so gut 50 also ich habe nur
noch funktioniert hat glück dass eben
die rhodo man einigermaßen gottes nicht
ja also funktioniert die kraft gesagt
prozent ab wie es machbar ist systeme
den haben
das büro eine gewisse bin allein für
austria dann ist wenigstens bin ich
immer geflüchtet war
am stand der schuld tag beschließt am
mittag abgrund zieht um dich um karamell
also der mega blick und alles fühlt sich
mehr komisch und wirtschaftliche lösung
vor dem unwort der stressige gefühl
musst du im herzen hasst wie mir ist
schon deshalb nicht kompensieren und
dann stößt man etwas gemacht und fakten
eltern halt brauchte ich habe weder
faktisch wieder ali und dann von der
verfolger und schwach so oft langfristig
ist es einfach keine lösung und das
schön finde ich aber ich würde jetzt auf
den moment einfach via kabel kam ich
dass ich hier so überbleibsel von mein
kampf und grüne haben rechtfertigt es
geschafft haben das mache mir webseiten
zeigen
ja ja
das sind meistens die heimliche der
schule gemacht haben natürlich mega
schlimm sich sonst da habe ich versucht
in ich sehne aus nieder
wir haben da oben einen der mit die
schlimmsten ist mega ob der schnee
kaufkraft
er ist schlink sie außerdem ist sie dass
es einfach anders kommen kaum nach
wirklich sehr viel mehr geld sie mit der
vom mitbekommen weil er verletzt hat das
hat will es dass in einer schlacht geht
es mir schlecht und das hat mich
überhaupt nicht weh land überhaupt nicht
passt aber kein geld
sie finanzieren sollen sie durch
schlachten oder meistens zumindest der
familie steht ein umzug bevor die
siedlung muss einem neubau weichen
emil wird einiges hinter sich lassen
kann so viele sachen machen und zieht
die dämmung verbracht
ganz fertig schaute nur tests immer
alles anders
[Musik]
während emil allmählich zur ruhe kommt
stecken andere noch mitten in der krise
ein montagmorgen im dezember in der
klinik für kinder und jugendpsychiatrie
in zürich
[Musik]
morgen miteinander wie ich die nach
station eins hat der patient den
suizidversuch am ausgang gegangen
im ko spiel wurde sie genäht und kam
dann zu uns auf station 2 hat eine
patientin an dem tag sowohl den
suizidversuch ihrer freundin auf dem
zimmer im heim miterlebt als auch die
eigene mutter hat am gleichen tag
suizidversuch begangen deswegen ist die
patientin auch digital geworden und
wollte freiwillig aufgenommen werden
ansonsten haben wir gestern noch emanuel
eine patientin aufgenommen nach
suizidversuchen berichte auch zürich
genau denn schon über 18 der wollte
eigentlich gerne ins chris intervention
zentrum
die haben aber gestern nach ihn
abgelehnt da war der vater auch wirklich
sehr enttäuscht
und da ist einfach die frage so geht es
nicht mehr weiter die rufen jedes
wochenende hier an
der junge ist belastet hat ständig immer
wieder krisen wird immer wieder suizidal
und droht mittlerweile auch ganz
deutlich den eltern dass er sich
umbringen wird wochenende in der
psychiatrie sind häufig sehr schwierig
aber so heftig wie jetzt das buch ein
dass ich erst aber es konnte immer
wieder vorüber für jugendliche halt auch
in der klinik selber verletzen oder aber
versuchen das lebensnahe während der
muskel wenn sie wieder daheim sind in
der gewohnten umgebung dass das er
überforderung darstellt und und den ist
es wichtig dass man hat schnell reagiert
und und der jugendliche wieder eine
notwendige schutz gibt ja
gefeit gegen krisen ist niemand ein bis
zwei von zehn jugendlichen leiden unter
psychischen oder physischen störungen
die fachleute auch als folge des
erhöhten erwartungsdruck us werten dass
die rate der vollendeten suizid im
jugendalter nicht zugenommen hat mehr
diese phänomene von suizidalität und
selbstverletzungen
wir denken dass es damit zu tun hat dass
die jugendlichen heutzutage eben auch
frühe hilfe suchen und frühe hilfe
bekommen früher war das ja ein absolutes
tabu da war dann jemand der suizide war
ganz auf sich selbst gestellt und dann
ist es natürlich auch er dazu gekommen
dass dann vielleicht also wie suizid
leider auch verändert wird sieht dem
tisch wenn man gut ich bin endlich
selber ich mache ohne blödsinn wie zb
alkohol rauchen hitze ich bin sehr offen
mit dem thema tod nach gold
ich kann immer liegen zum punkte womit
die richtig ich weiß ja selbst aus und
ja ich mag einfach nicht brauchst du
dich nur wenn das haupt folge hätte dass
europa stoff oder wenn ich etwas also
denn selbst das hat so der richter
klassik war okay ich bin deutscher bis
folk vorne und kassler hand jungs
schönheits lustig gemacht heute anrufen
letzter platz sieben und dann hat es
doch so zeige die kabine chillen und
wenn ich das nicht geschafft haben dann
wenn man ich möchte dafür bestraft
wir studieren was gemacht dass er keine
gefahr mehr leads und dann mit dem oft
weil ich nicht an werde das man sieht
dass man schlecht und dann mehrfach
klebte man halt größer und das ja auch
nicht dann aber wieder angefangen mir
hitze und jetzt ist es weg sodass er
macht täglich wir beide jetzt mit wem
das messer gesehen wenn du dir etwas was
es geht um das was ich für dich papa
positiv ich spielte schmerz also ich
mach das auch nur ab jetzt in phase
ernsthaft bank der stapi sagst du jetzt
steht samt foto ta brauchen bis er voll
da bin ich besoffen occean gefunden
jetzt sollen wir medikamenten ja dann
ist das halt ich bin im moment lebe ich
bin ich bloß nicht um wenn ich weiß dass
es geht immer in liebe geht wo mich
keiner und ich weiß mit dem zerstören
der dass das möchte ich nicht
während eineinhalb jahren hat der benni
regelmäßig psychotherapie stunden
besucht seine krise die ihren höhepunkt
in depressionen zieht gedanken und einer
essstörung gefunden hatte überwand er
mehr und mehr den ersten teil der matura
hatte er hinter sich
benny fühlte sich stabil da erreichte
ihn die nachricht sein vater sei einem
herzinfarkt erlegen
biochemische und nacheinander afrikaner
hat extra geführt dass jetzt lappen
wirklicher was so manchen untergebracht
aber es ist wie es hat mich stark
gemacht und alle mini andere problem hat
plötzlich viel pauschal was uns auch
mega viel weniger gurte werden ich liebe
auch immer durch verlaufen war das beste
das ist gesünder wird sondern bis auf
mich selber gestellt
ich bin so nachdem ursprünglich gesagt
bin ich einfach so rettig sie so
pragmatisch einfach sitzen alles machen
und ich kann nicht immer bringt ganz oft
an
die sich wieder mal als sie bin profi
sieht für mich kommen und dann brach der
anteile sind lässt sich vollständig aus
- und ich bin wie stark sie obwohl ich
die jungs 7
aber schon wieso der moment bin ich am 8
plötzlich sitzt so sponsoring
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich alles anders plötzlich
muss er selber zahlen
in form situation anderer ca das ist
leicht heftig sie das was uns gelöst hat
[Musik]
simak ist dass sie sich auf seine
familie und seine kollegen verlassen
hätten und jetzt ziemlich blau minute
noch einen toten vater wo alles
politisch womit sehr viele sachen müsse
aber vorher nicht vorher für ein gemacht
wurde sind oder das ist ein moment der
momente gebe zu ich kann das alles ein
herz gefasst und elf wochen später
hätten sie überhaupt und wird weil alles
wieder
man geht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ich glaub so wie er sich
präsentiert das fast in echtzeit
das ist ja die sitte wo immer man locker
das auch weiter keine ruhe bringen und
eine sportliche persönlichkeit von den
politischen aufstieg knapp
er hat eine unglaubliche ob musik und
das tanzen und das alles
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die waage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
denn die möchte seine leidenschaft zum
beruf machen
deshalb bewarb er sich an der stage
school in hamburg sieht trotz der
sommerferien zurück und in hamburgs s-
oder musical school sowie energetisch
neugeborene hat wahnsinnige energie und
vor allem aus einer sondern unbedingt
hat wien auch wenn es auch gut wenn das
tor erzielte zahl dem projekt einfach
wirklich jessica albers rechts und links
ist und was für stimmige grad sind
erzählt systems dabei muss eine kommune
die genossen und 18 uhr cantate sehr
früh kommen
trotz erkältung und fieber der show must
go on
eine bühnenprobe lässt benny nicht
ausfallen
[Musik]
das zusammen
die positive und das auch noch beleidigt
[Musik]
sie also lernt der juno und bäder in der
klinik kennen
seit einem jahr sind die drei
befreundete ungebrochen
doch da sieht man wo neben der
alltagsstress und gespielt sagt wirklich
soziale medien und so schaut schon immer
so dass das alles auch es sind
wahnsinnig nett kollege sagt zum
beispiel gleich abgenommen
ok ja vielleicht ist es ist kompliment
konzentriert danke ich habe einfach
gemacht dass überhaupt nicht wagen es
eigentlich geht und wie sie mit mir und
meinen verstand sich auch nicht einfach
mit so nitz handel aber panik wir sind
einfach locker dass damit noch nicht nur
schlag auf schlag
[Musik]
jetzt eben verändert seit er denken kann
hat man so viel kamera dann aber und
anna mangas natürlich nicht einfach
zugemacht als auch das kind und hans
köhler schaden
das tue dem wenn du in soziale situation
bis sie weniger platz und das du
situation betrachtet ist ja ok
doch auf einmal kriegt die kreisstadt
lernt das ja dass du nicht alles so mega
fisch zu herzen nimmt und was eine
gewisse spieler über die schlechte
ausstattung kann dank der mehr als es
keine fehler time geschafft einiges mehr
[Musik]
als kleiner junge hatte benny während
zwei jahren ballettstunden besucht seit
der bestandenen aufnahmeprüfung an der
musicalschule in hamburg nimmt er wieder
unterricht
[Musik]
die arische ruhige rote und sich selber
erfunden
mit dem tanzen mit dem singen also durch
einfach nicht so konzentriert darüber
was andere danken allen klassen habe mir
etwas die zukunft macht und gestresst
und der benni hat das in geld also er
weiß was er macht hat jetzt die
perspektive mit dem musical schule und
ich glaube das hat ihm aber jeder hat
sie geschlachtet
es ist früher morgen auf der station
eins in der klinik für jugendpsychiatrie
in zürich mit der sorge mache ok es noch
einen vize-posten eine enge begleitung
durch fachleute aus medizin und pflege
gibt sicherheit auch auf den stationären
abteilungen steigen die zahlen der
hospitalisierungen jahr für jahr anders
als auf den kinderstationen sind bei den
jugendlichen mehrheitlich mädchen
platziert jede patientin bekommt ein
individuelles programm zum essen trifft
man sich auch der streng reglementierte
klinikalltag hilft dabei die krise zu
überwinden
wir denken dass die jugendlichen
heutzutage versuchen mit suizidalität
und selbstverletzung auf eine nicht
funktionierende art ihre probleme zu
lösen sie erhoffen sich eine besserung
viele wollen ja nicht sterben sie wollen
einfach so nicht mehr weiterleben
[Musik]
emil war zweimal in der
kindertagespflege kurze zeit auch
stationär in dieser zeit führte er
tagebuch ich habe sehr viel mit unserer
sache beschäftigt also schlafen ganz
vorne gegangen ist nicht so gut
geschlafen da der schulbank im schlaf
beherrschen sie wurde danach ob ich nun
sehr unsichere web
und da nicht halt schon angst kriegen
jetzt mich zu etwas verlange tiere alles
verliert und was ist rosig alles mache
es kurz hier dazu zwingen ja die
befürchtung bewahrheitet nein überhaupt
nicht
das carling es ist immer sehr offen wir
können über alles reden transport das
life-ness okay sind
das ist so dass die aktion wird
vonlanthen nach zwei monaten in der
tagesklinik stand erstmals ein austritt
auf die euphorie folgte panik was nun
wirklich nicht ganz so häufig begangen
obwohl ich etwas sport wenn der schimmel
ist es fix die so einfach so für die
eigene sicherheit man garantieren hat
mich heute sitzt die hand tragen macht
das das ist das können wir nicht
verantworten dass card also könnte die
sich rapide
obwohl sie doch sie sind ja hat er denn
das so klar ist aber auch selbst
verschickt sie euch wird noch allen
besser gehen wenn ich nicht mehr da war
das hat oft gesagt
[Musik]
noch am tag des auftrittes kam emil als
notfall zurück in die klinik zu seiner
sicherheit auch über nacht
[Musik]
ich bin von mir eigentlich immer dort
wollte also die ganze aufgestaute
emotionen so einfach so ich habe auch
irgendwo für so schlimm ist also für
ältere was hatte das problem gemacht
halt erstellt also danke was alles das
machen nur als und was damit alles recht
wenn ich hier bin und das ist dann
wieder fit machen nur als und dann fehlt
mir vielleicht steht wieder ist und so
karl entfernt klar
[Musik]
was ich anders machen würde ich weiß
nicht so genau
[Musik]
das wird alles noch schlimmer
wir können wirklich vielen helfen also
in dem alter ist es schon so jugendliche
sind ja noch nicht fertig in ihrer
identitätsbildung und wenn sie dann die
unterstützung bekommen die jugendlichen
und die familien wir beraten ja auch die
eltern dann die dann da auch mithelfen
können dann können wir wirklich sehr
sehr vielen helfen dass sie aus der
krise wieder rausfinden der super
gemacht und durch tätig und dann beim
kompostieren und die nächsten fünf
jahren wir so das kleid was ich mache
wird und ich kann gott so viele gäste in
die letzte offizielle therapiestunden
kann und ich muss sicherlich beide
festgestellt dass es mir super gut und
das therapie metro und ich les portman
ist immer wieder schließen erlaubt sind
und eine flotte nach selber christus
machen haben forschende lang bin ich
habe genau gewusst was machen und karl
fleschen und ich weiß nicht wie das der
krise und holz das telefon
warum nicht
was dort bin
will ich jetzt ganz ganz lang trainiert
hat und jetzt eigentlich in der mall
jetzt etwas gutes an ist eine pflanze
musste
[Musik]
emil ist unterdessen 15 geworden und am
neuen ort angekommen
auch er sieht voller zuversicht in die
zukunft
ich wollte mal krimi studiere und zwecke
berichten auch als clever und machen das
einzige schulfach mini pool heute
bewundert so also das macht mir spaß
arminia familie umwelt verstand anfangen
verstarb wie alles funktioniert und
warum es funktioniert und dass ich bin
gar nicht mehr will ich lieber sachen
arbeitslager und wenigstens einen
bruchteil von dem zwei starts gehabt
dass ich es so bewältigen
kann methode klar mit mir selber und
sogar als wenn ich nichts finde das war
so ist alba der vergangene und das hat
aber dafür das ist okay so perfekt ist
es okay halt alles kann dass die andere
punkt und kann ich das ist einfach mega
wertvoll für mich also dass panik
besuchten soll sich das jetzt so haben
was für eine herausforderung in der
pubertät sich selbst und seinen platz in
der gesellschaft zu finden
dass dies nicht auf anhieb gelingt ist
nachvollziehbar dass es ohne druck
besser geht ebenfalls
[Musik]